la montagne la rivière du prêcheur
sujettes au terrifiant l'art et tout au
bord une entreprise des maisons
d'habitation sur l'autre rive
d'autres quartiers inondables et l'école
primaire pour protéger les personnes et
les biens la commune n'a pas
d'alternative
elle doit modifier son plan d'occupation
des sols en homo créer de nouveaux
quartiers pour reloger les plus
vulnérables à commencer par l'école qui
sera reconstruite d'ici deux ans en haut
du bourg nous avons décidé de prendre le
taureau par les cornes pour vraiment
envisager un projet en diderot
spatialisation avec une école qui sera
la tête de poing d'un projet qui sera en
même temps une école refuse et autour de
cette école on va aménager on va dire
une nouvelle partie du bourg mais sans
trop s'éloigner de l'actuelle bout pour
éviter justement l'étalement urbain
entre rivière et littoral environ 300
personnes sont à jour invité à
abandonner les zones à risque et dans
les réunions de quartier l'idée commence
à faire son chemin
il ya quand même un peu de crainte parce
que les gens ont peur à même le sol de
la rivière djabou roman c'est à dire les
sirènes ils sont un petit peu
quand il manquait ce qui va se passer et
quand ils incitent langues disent ou là
là on a des problèmes et quand un
tremblement de terre avec les cela me
pose pas mal de questions si c'est ça le
risque de pêcher pendant deux ans une
équipe de quatre architectes apportera
son concours technique au futur plan
d'urbanisme avec pour méthode
l'immersion dans la vie des quartiers et
pour finalité l'élaboration d'un nouveau
type d'habitat écologique et respectueux
des coutumes et qu'on comprenne comment
les gens vivent ensemble quelles sont
les structures sociales les relations de
voisinage les relations de solidarité
entre elles tous les habitants et c'est
ça qui va nous permettre de mettre au
point le projet on vient pas avec un
projet qu'on impose sur un territoire et
ensuite on explique aux gens comment ils
vont devoir s'adapter à ce projet non
pas du tout aujourd'hui c'est l'inversé
c'est pas uniquement réagir au risque se
mettre en sécurité bien sûr il faut
faire ça mais c'est aussi se dire on
arrive en plus à être un modèle
d'aménagement en milieu tropical en un
demi siècle la mer s'est rapproché de 30
à 100 mètres selon les quartiers et si
les riverains sont très attachés à leur
mode de vie
l'accroissement du danger et décidera à
partir vers les hauteurs il faut y aller
je présente ma vie et les autres espaces
étant donné je suis la présidente
décorticage allez on y va tout le monde
ira à aa
mais ça va je me déplace je serai dans
la partie qui me donne comme ça de la
chlorophylle et le sud en longueur de la
file est là où la plupart des
championnats possible puisque nous
sommes vraiment dans une zone à lui ce
que je voulais créer un mauvais temps on
oblige des points de vue soit mais
plutôt les prêts chotin doivent
réinventer leur espace et leur mode de
vie
un immense défi qui s'imposera à toutes
les populations du littoral
[Musique]